[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم القياده المركزيه للقوات
البحريه الامريكيه تعلن انها اسقطت طائره
مسيره وصاروخ بالستيا مضادا للسفن تابعين
لانصار الله الحوثي جنوب البحر الاحمر وفي
مدينه نيويورك اغلق مئات المتظاهرين
الامريكيين مدخل مبنى مركز التجاره
العالمي منددين بالعدوان الاسرائيلي على
قطاع غزه في اطار تجمع حمل عنوان اغرقوا
مدينه نيويورك من اجل فلسطين وتجدون
المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في رابط بالتعليق
الاول كيف تعلن مقتل 10 اشخاص واصابه 70
في اكبر هجوم جوي روسي منذ اندلاع الحرب
قبل عامين باستخدام طائرات مسيره وصواريخ
كروز استهدفت البنيه التحتيه في العاصمه
كيف ومختلف مناطق
اوكرانيا ولايه مين الامريكيه تصدر قرارا
ينص على عدم اهليه دونالد ترامب للمشاركه
في انتخابات الولايه التمهيديه لانتخابات
الرئاسه المقبله لتصبح الولايه الثانيه
التي تستبعد الرئيس السابق من الانتخابات
بعد ان اصدرت المحكمه العليا في كولورادو
حكمها الذي ازاله من الاقتراع في وقت سابق
هاله الديون العالميه تتصاعد الى مستويات
غير مسبوقه وفقا لاحدث تقرير من معهد
التمويل الدولي الذي كشف ان حجم الديون
العالميه بلغ حتى نهايه ديسمبر من العام
الحالي نحو
307 ترليونات دولار ما يشكل ارتفاعا كبيرا
ب 10 ترليونات دولار على الاقل عن ارقام
العام الذي
سبقه الى
اللقاء